una multitud se reúne frente al comando
militar del sudeste en Sao Paulo tres
días después del triunfo de la izquierda
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva en las
elecciones presidenciales del domingo
los manifestantes piden una intervención
militar y desconocen los resultados de
los comicios en los que perdió su
candidato Yair bolso
estamos pidiendo hoy como en 1964 que
activemos el código 142 que es el código
de intervención militar para que nuestro
país no se convierta en un país
comunista
comunista el ambiente político en Brasil
sigue siendo tenso a pesar de que el
martes bolsonaro autorizó el traspaso
del poder al nuevo gobierno el
mandatario no reconoció directamente la
victoria de Lula y muchos de los
manifestantes se ponen a la llegada del
izquierdista a la presidencia
los conceptos
los conceptos y propuestas del candidato
que resultó electo interfieren y afectan
lo que yo creo como cristiano y como
Ciudadano de esta nación y
como en Río de Janeiro el panorama es
similar donde manifestantes también
rechazaron frente al cuartel general del
ejército La derrota electoral de
bolsonaro
en la concentración cuestionaron al
tribunal superior electoral
estamos aquí de manera legal pacífica
democrática para dar un contragolpe este
sistema criminal corrupto que administró
las elecciones brasileñas a través del
tribunal superior electoral ha dado un
golpe en las urnas
durante la campaña bolsonaro había
insinuado que no reconocería los
resultados unas afirmaciones que luego
desmintió sin embargo estas encendieron
las alarmas a nivel nacional e
internacional human right Swatch había
asegurado que las afirmaciones de un
posible fraude electoral eran infundadas
y hostiles para el sistema democrático
en Brasil